Một bài thác bà, ngoài trường ý và á bác rộng gí lê nả mù của tấn công mà tây rãn cho là giòn Mỹ
tính hành nhằm và nhằm máy khường mạnh nếu biển chiến đạo Khương sở về Phuê sia.
Ông rộng chỉ cho biết của tấn công đàn gửi lĩnh mùn công nước của khoảng 8 mila lần.
Đừng thời cạnh báo vực nhảm vào cơ sở hạ tình dịch sử, có thể tạo ra thì lệng huy em.
Các trình giá nình cũng nhận định vực nhắm vào cơ sử khường mạnh.
Có thể làm ra tăng đáng kể cũng độ huy em của xin đột.
Cô vực của hội đau mù hợp távu vệnh hiện có hơn 4 chăm nhà máy hưởng mạnh.
Cung có khoảng 4 mila vần trong lượng nước hưởng mạnh tần cầu,
và là 1 nước sinh hoạt tru yếu của Nhu Cú xa.
Cung ngày Mỹ bể xưa ra cũng đã lần đầu tiên tiến hành có khu hồn cách,
nhằm và các khó dự trễ sầu, bán như liệu tại thủ đô tây hề ràn của Iran.
Một số khó đã trình tên lợi trình được tấn công.
Đám lại, cung ngày lực gợng về bình kinh nảm dịch sở Iran cho biết đã phóng tên lửa khi bà xích hàng,
và bà bình nhà máy học dầu, tình có hay phà của Iran,
và tấn công đất chàng như các nước hại quân trua phà tại bà rành.
Nơi đặt tru xử hạm đổ nâm của Mỹ.
Chua đó, tổng thống Iran là số,
và gia skeen tuyên bố tài ra sẽ tránh tấn công gương lãn dịn,
nếu lãnh thổ của họ không bị sự dụng li đến hành có cuộc tấn công nhằm với Iran.
Thưa dịn biến mở cho thấy xuống đổ dựa các bình tý tuần mở giống,
ra khó mục tiêu năng lượng trễ nược.
Lãnh giá các ngay về威 cơ liều tháng và tất cả đồng tựa an đing năng lượng cho cuộc trung đông.